things you were watching ColdFusion TV
hey guys welcome to another ColdFusion
video to go go here so today it's a bit
different as you can see because I'm in
my room and so are you I guess all five
hundred thousand potential of you
watching that's just incredible to think
about but anyway so the reason I'm doing
this video which is a question of an
answer video which you probably could
have told by the title is because I'm
actually working on two videos at the
moment one is how big is General
Electric and the other one is the story
of Nikola Tesla so with these videos
have actually taken quite a bit of time
and a bit longer than I would have
expected it all anticipated so in the
meantime I thought I might as well do
something a little bit different just to
get just to keep you guys filled in so
it's not just a big gap of silence so I
actually went out to Twitter and I asked
you guys if you'd like to know a bit of
a question and answer session for cold
fusion so you guys are quite receptive
and you guys said yes so here is my
question and answer session with you
guys let's get straight into it so the
first one I got here let's have a look
is when did I start making YouTube
videos so I started making YouTube
videos in 2007 and the reason for that
is just just for fun I just loved video
editing when I was a bit younger and I'm
just started doing things that I thought
were funny
editing random stuff and stuff with my
friends and also just music videos and
things that I made but had nothing to do
with tech not like it is today I really
that only started when I got the HTC hd2
and discovered like a combination of
apps that you could put together on your
phone and make it work in a way that no
one had really seen before it really was
kind of like new at the time so a lot of
people were like oh how did you do that
and they wanted to know a tutorial and
if you're interested you can type in 3d
UI on this channel and go back and have
a
look at that and you'll see what I mean
kind of was kind of really new at the
time and from that I started doing doing
tutorials and how to instruct people to
make the UI which is now the Vox this
app which you can get from the
description below if you really want it
from there it kind of turned into
reviews when I got my galaxy note and
from there kind of branched off into
what it is today so kind of like an
all-encompassing society slash
technology channel that focuses on the
past present and future if you like so
quite quite something unique and
different there and it's just cuz it's
my interests and that's what it is today
so when I just start back in 2007 had
nothing to do a tech and now it's Kirk
Toby change that's the answer to that
okay the next question do I ever
consider myself doing regular reviews of
smartphones and the answer to that is at
this time okay let me put it this way I
kind of like to look at everything in a
macro sense first so with the smartphone
industry if you take into account things
like economic situations or the growth
of the industry or just the cyclic
nature of industries and how you know
that the hype cycle and and how things
types mature I think smartphones in a
whole as an industry are starting to
reach that maturity level so what that
really means is right now manufacturers
can sink a whole bunch of R&D into
things and only get a little bit of
return out a little bit of value for the
user so that would be a high-resolution
screen or a slightly faster processor so
things ranging back
a few years ago only were a
revolutionary trend that came out was
twice as good as the last and just
totally faster and new and nowadays it
seems like there's a bit of stagnation
happening and that's only natural
because market saturation is almost 70
to 80% in most of the Western markets
what can you really do after that most
people have one they don't really want
to go out and get another one every
single year because I've done that once
or twice already so in general
innovation slowing market adopt a
adaptation is slowing and I just see
like in the next few years it's not
really as exciting as it once was a few
years back for me personally anyway so
I'd want to be excited about something
when I make a video and smartphones just
don't do it as they used it for me so
now sorry guys if you guys were hoping
for a lot more reviews I just feel like
the macro story is more interesting
right now than individual devices now
don't get me wrong if something comes
out that blows a lot of things out of
the water it's got a lot of new
innovations and it's just incredible
yeah sure I'd be keen to have a look at
that but otherwise right now it doesn't
really seem like exact grabbing me as
much as it used to so that's the answer
to that just thought I might tell you
guys that one another question how do I
get all the information that I do
actually let me read this properly how
do I get the information that I do in
such a short period of time and how do I
get the information that nobody knows
how to get so I wouldn't say no one else
knows how to get it but I'd say that
it's kind of I don't know you have to do
a bit of keyword wizardry to to know to
get very specific things but you know I
go through all the normal sources that
people would so like for reddit to get
the macro picture of what's going around
on around in the tech world and that
links off to like TechRadar or
TechCrunch or whatever other news outlet
there is also sometimes look at journal
papers and journal articles that are a
link to the story stuff from academics
and it's a whole variety of things but
the way that I put it together and get
it together so quickly and efficiently I
guess you could say is because you know
from a young age when I was a teenager
and all that kind of stuff I just loved
learning about technology and science
and why things happened and how they
worked and from there I kind of have a
background of how things relate to each
other and I can see the parallels so
when some when a new story comes out of
something with them drones for example
like the last video I did then I can
think back to when I was like 15 or 16
learning about fly-by-wire and how that
was kind of like a intelligent flight
system for aircraft and how that came
about and the parallels between that and
reigns with a pretty bad example but
stuff that relate to each other I can
say that relates to that that relates to
that and I can kind of coalesce it
before it gets to be too cumbersome I
hope that answers your question
onto the next one goes alright so we're
going to do a couple more before we end
up because my camera battery symbol is
dying a flash which means I don't have
much time right I so what this is a
quick one what was my major in college
so I studied mechanical engineering with
a focus on materials engineering and
also a bit of marketing as well and
post-grad another question what is the
most innovative company of the 21st
century I'm gonna have to give this one
to Google because if you look at what
they do from Google search which is what
everyone uses even like YouTube everyone
uses that as well and if you even look
at the stuff that they're doing that's a
bit left-field so like the acquisition
of Boston Dynamics and their robotic
stuff and they're AI these are all such
very new things that are starting to
really change people's lives and even
Android even 50% or above a smartphone
sold in the world Android so Google
really is one of those companies that
has just come in
you know from 1998 a real baby company
in this change so much and you know some
of you guys will be wondering what about
Samsung or Apple we know they've got a
huge market cap
take Samsung for instance all the
industries that they're in have been
around for a long time so take shipping
for example that's been around for ages
or you know appliances or TV is that
kind of thing there's a those are quite
old industries but Google's at the
cutting edge of a lot of stuff
innovating and affecting a lot of people
so yeah for sure the most innovation
come innovative company of the 21st
century my pick would be Google yeah
that's what I think about that one you
know what I think I think that's about
it so yeah that is my question answer
session so hopefully you guys enjoy that
or got something out of it at least
and you actually I just want to point
out one thing I didn't have a couple of
questions about starting a YouTube
channel or what to do let's see how my
battery goes but basically I would say
if you're going to start a YouTube
channel make sure you figure out why
you're doing it so is it to encourage
people and inspire people make people
laugh or teach people educate people is
it from monetary aspects figure out why
you're doing it first and then think how
much effort he willing to put in because
it's going to take a lot you have to be
passionate about what you're doing cause
it takes a lot of time to build up and
to learn how to actually get better but
you know don't be discouraged if you're
just starting out because if you really
do have a passion for it I think you'll
do well also make sure you have all the
use all the resources you can so get
good software like I use Adobe Premiere
and Adobe After Effects make sure you
learn tutorials you can do that off
youtube there's a lot of free ones
people just wanting to help other people
out watch those that's kind of how I
learnt a little bit
and yeah just be passionate and
dedicated and just enjoy it make sure
you enjoy it as well like pay attention
to work because you'll enjoy it more and
yeah I think I think you just have to be
yourself as well that's another thing
you know a lot of people want to start a
YouTube channel and say I just want to
be just like that guy just gonna be the
next that but then you're not being
yourself 1 & 2 everyone has already seen
that person who you're going to try and
be in trying to copy so people can see
straight through that and you're not
being genuine so I don't think that's a
good way to go obviously take
inspiration and good things that you see
in that other channel that you want to
emulate but don't be another clone copy
sorry but yeah I think I think that's
about time hey I don't want to stay here
forever and I guess you guys don't
either so I don't wrap it up now so
thanks for watching guys and I guess
I'll see you guys again soon for the
next video cheers guys